this guy's been gone weeks we need a new
top five there's something creepy going
on this door I'm not crazy
gone
[Applause]
[Music]
Ayana Heather
get away from that
[Music]
I'm back guys it's made to real me I'm
back don't listen to him
[Music]
I'm the real Walter no he's a duplicate
like the last one look I don't have time
to explain but you've gotta believe me
stop lying to them if we kill him he'll
disappear like all the others guys he's
a fake I'm telling him hold on I know
how to tell who the real Walter is what
is the worst sort on air a Power Ranger
series turbo damn it there's only one
way to settle this it's a top five off
Power Rangers turbo is not remembered to
finally by most fans it represented a
low point for the Zordon era just like
that costume was a low point for you
this season started with a theatrical
release called turbo a Power Rangers
movie it introduced new powers a new
villain and a new Ranger tell him tell
him who was it was a little kid that's
right the new Blue Ranger and
replacement for Rocky was a little
almost orphan named Justin also is
all-around an alpha five leave early in
the series so it was a big change of
status quo the problem was this season
didn't do much of anything different or
exciting except focus on cars well at
least the range is finally graduated
from high school true that these are the
top five worst Power Rangers turbo
episodes stop copying me number five the
robot Ranger this episode is about a
group of imposters sound familiar in
this Twilight Zone twisted episode of
Power Rangers turbo Justin starts to
notice something strange about his
fellow Rangers Ashley and TJ seem to
have circuits in their wrists and Carl's
his face even pops off this leads to the
young blue Ranger to come to the
conclusion that his team has been
replaced by robots however all that is
put on hold when divatox 6 her newest
monster flash head-on angel Grove
actually like flash head he's a fun
villain who asked you you dump duplicate
spoilers in case you care about the
twist in a 21 year old episode of Power
Rangers
Justin ends up being a robot as well
these robotic Rangers were made by Zoran
and alpha 5 on El Tarr to help the real
Rangers I guess honestly I'm not sure
why they were created
all since they go back to LTR at the end
of the episode and what could be more
annoying than one Justin
- Justin's talking to each other about
playing soccer and on both TJ's weird
delivery and you have one of the worst
episodes and one of the worst seasons
hit a little close to home yet desperate
doppelganger that's it now it's my turn
number four the whole lie the concept of
this episode is that the Rangers are all
shot with the deception blaster and
can't stop live hey do we have one of
those
Jim do we have a deception blaster stay
out of the scene divatox ends the
monstermouth peace to earth where he
first shoots justin's then the other
Rangers with his deception blaster they
aren't able to tell the truth and every
time they lie another piranha Tron shows
up the numbers eventually overcome the
Rangers until Justin can find a way to
once again tell the truth this is just
lame back in the muddy Morphin days this
would have at the very least been a fun
episode but by the time turbo came
around even too dumb fun concepts became
incredibly boring
it's dull it's slow and it was hard to
keep my eyes open watching this in the
90s and today this was one of those
episodes that cemented the fact that the
intangible magic of Power Rangers was
gone and it wouldn't be back into the
following season terrible analysis
you're pathetic number three the song of
confusion confusion confusion confusion
confusion confusion annoyed yet Cassie
and her friend Vicki decide to start a
band and hold auditions for some reason
a whole other band called crash in the
creeps try out and play the song of
confusion
Cassie joins them and they're overly
catchy song starts to affect the
citizens of Angel Grove later it's
discovered that crash and the creeps are
actually a band of monsters who worked
for divatox with Cassie leading the
charge the turbo Rangers must put a stop
to these maniacal musicians confusion
confusion confusion okay I'm annoyed now
good confusion confusion confess on was
to be annoying but they did it a little
too well by the end it seemed like
everyone had sang that day
song and there's not much more to it
what's the opposite of a one-hit wonder
because that's what this episode was
annoying annoying annoying
number two bicycle built for the Blues
this is another Justin centric episode
starting to see a pattern it's Justin's
birthday and while the Rangers are
planning a surprise party for him he is
gifted a bicycle he thinks is from his
father but is actually from divatox and
her new monster big Burpo yes big Burpo
one I guess what her gimmick is she
burps a lot Justin is stuck on the bike
and can't stop pedaling the other
Rangers sense of urgency increases when
they find out a bomb is set to detonate
the bike in mere minutes I get the
feeling they wanted to have a fart
monster but had to keep it a little more
tame for the kids this is a very early
episode of the season and boy does it
set the pace you think this would be a
little exciting since we have a bomb set
to go off and kill one of the main
characters but it's so boring they must
have had to try and make it this boring
because there's no way a show about
super power teenage crime fighters
should be this bland if you want to put
your kids to sleep have them watch this
episode if big burp --is belching
doesn't keep them awake I'm sure they'll
drift off to have much more interesting
dreams burping hilarious see and the
number one worst episode of Power
Rangers turbo is the spirit of the woods
air Uttam does that name mean anything
to you while on his morning jog
TJ runs into a young boy in the woods
named heir u 10
TJ soon realizes air utan isn't a normal
boy he's the spirit of the woods or
something when divatox finds out she
sends her monster lord litter to capture
air you can and use his powers for evil
you ready for this here we go can you
figure it out Congrats here's a power
cookie it took TJ a lot longer to figure
this out in the episode this is
basically the Power Rangers equivalent
of Michael Jackson's earth saw hey I
like that song you would maybe the kids
actually Jesus he randomly stands on
water at one point two
any case this episode is the worst of
the worst
this season sucks turbo is a disgrace
you can check out my personal channel
for a review of turbo a Power Rangers
movie that just went up today you mean
my personal channel we get it you don't
like turbo but for as bad as the season
was do you really hate it yes I hate it
absolutely it's got awful are you
kidding me give me that it's good to
have you back it's good to be back where
have you been this whole time and what
is up with that door it's a long story
there's a lot I gotta fill you guys in
on what's happening it's him
me going missing the door the duplicates
it's all because of him
[Music]
hello old chum
[Laughter]
[Music]
you